you're more likely in this country to
hear a sermon in a church about
climate change the so-called climate
crisis
or about black lives matter or about
brexit than you are about jesus christ
that to me is sad
if i'm being charitable i'll say that
these people are well-intentioned
and
they're doing what they think is best if
i'm feeling less charitable and more
cynical i'll say they've actually lost
the faith
or they've found a new religion
i think people a lot of people at this
point are worshiping
the environment
welcome to episode 137 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson
this episode features calvin robinson i
met calvin during my trip to oxford for
the debate on the ethics of meat
consumption that hasn't been posted yet
not sure if it ever will be anyway
calvin is a political advisor a
newscaster for gb news a writer for the
telegraph in the daily mail and a senior
fellow at the uk think tank policy
exchange
more importantly though at least for
this episode he's finishing holy orders
to become an anglican priest calvin
talks about his training to become a
priest about worshiping new idols things
like the environment in the absence of
religion woke culture at church his
conversion to anglicanism and the
anglican church calvin wasn't raised in
a religious household so i asked about
his experience finding god rationality
scripture and his personal religious
beliefs please subscribe if you enjoy
this episode or this content before we
get started this episode is brought to
you by schwenk grylls hands down the
best grill i've ever used or i wouldn't
be talking about them schwinn grills are
made in america they're portable
infrared grills that heat up to 1500
degrees fahrenheit being able to do that
at home is something else that
exceptional taste when the steaks black
on the outside and red on the inside
kidding you don't have to use swank to
make your steaks black they do mired
reactions beautifully i just like
blackened steaks like i'm not one of
those weird carnivores that eats
everything raw i like it crunchy this
girl makes the perfect food like a
steakhouse but in your backyard patio or
even out camping it doesn't smoke it's
super easy to clean and you get high
quality steakhouse worthy steaks in just
about three minutes or chicken wings
fish hamburgers vegetables whatever it
even has a pizza stone head to
schweinkgirls.com today and get 150 off
a schwank 1500 degree grill when using
promo code mp at checkout again that's
150 off over at shwinkgirls.com with
codemp at checkout
[Music]
calvin welcome to my podcast
an absolute pleasure michaela thank you
for the invitation
so we met
when i was just in the uk and we went
out for lunch yeah you had a very
interesting debate while you're over
here
i don't think i've ever actually walked
out of a debate before but i did walk
out of your debate but it wasn't because
of you
do you think they're gonna end up
posting it they haven't posted it yet uh
they probably will do they like to get
it all online but how won't it become
it's quite worrying isn't it
yeah so a brief background i i went to
oxford
to be part of their debate on whether or
not we should move beyond meat so it was
theoretically like three people on one
side that was supposed to be pro-meat
theoretically and three people on the
other side and it's going up online i'll
link it below if it's out by the time
this episode out is out but dad was
there calvin was there and one of the
people on the other side
how would you describe her well first of
all i mean you were fantastic and
someone else on the other team was
fantastic at giving arguments for or
against me that's what it should have
been about but then this other lady got
up and
well she started linking it to every
single work clause she could think of so
apparently eating meat is racist it's a
sign of white supremacy it's
misogynistic uh what were the other tick
boxes she went for i can't even remember
at this point but i was like this is not
even you can't argue against this
because it's not logic it's just pure
fantasy and it's delusional and these
people are just trying to virtue signal
in every single sentence it's all buzz
words all over the place it's what can
you do you just you can't i just walked
out just as a protest
i'm not standing for that ridiculousness
yeah i could i could hear you i could
see your father
i was
dying i've never it sounded
you couldn't write that if you tried it
was every single word
was filled with like
vitriol and hatred and wokeness it was
amazing
it's like this is the point we're
actually where the the good guys are
full of hatred for people who won't like
them or don't think like them and
somehow they think that they have a
virtue signal it's bonkers to me
yeah okay so before we we get to our
conversation
if anyone watching doesn't know who you
are could you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
uh yeah sure i'm not entirely sure
myself um
so
for your audience i'll give them a
little bit of insight that most people
don't know because because you do know
this about me i'm in oxford
i'm training for holy orders so i'm
reading theology at the moment um so i
will god willing be ordained as a priest
in this coming june in uh peter tied
um but that's that's that's my vocation
my calling is is public ministry but
what i do is i'm a public
broadcaster or a political commentator
people pay me for my opinions
essentially
okay i like that way of describing it
no because
people call me a journalist but i don't
think i am a journalist because i think
that would undermine people who have
gone to journalistic school and trained
in in the art of journalism you know i
don't report uh facts i don't fact find
i i give my opinion on the matter and i
usually try to bring that down to my
christian values and a good sense of
what i call morality um and point in the
direction of good uh rather than evil
which is a lot of the work stuff which
i'm sure we'll get to at some point but
you know i'm very
uh subjective in in my
broadcasting style so i wouldn't ever
call myself a journalist
how long have you been at oxford and
have you seen the progression of
wokeness like has it gotten
significantly worse since you started
there so i've only been here two years
uh thanks for thankfully my course is
only two years long um
i don't know if it's been progressive
but it's certainly a mixed bag this is
supposed to be the best university in
the world it's you know it's probably
the oldest unless you talk to people
it's probably the oldest english
language university in the world at
least and it's prestigious and renowned
for a lot of good reasons but i don't
see a lot of that at the moment so just
this week for example the university
have sent out the vice chancellor sent
out an email to all of the school
masters saying the government's response
to the new variant isn't strong enough
we need extra measures all social events
must be cancelled effectively
immediately cancel your christmas
parties do not socialize isolate
yourself and have your christmas lunch
by yourself it's like the the you know
from the top down it's entirely
woke in every aspect i've heard i've
heard the chancellor himself shilling
for china
and the student body is it is a mixed
bag there are good there's a good core
element of small c conservatives that
are fighting the good fight uh the roger
scrutin memorial lectures are a good um
uh embodiment of that but in in general
they are just as workers everywhere else
but you know queer theory gender theory
everyone wants to look like they're a
good person so they don't dare question
what's going on and just goes along with
it and i think complicity is is our
downfall
hmm
what did you do before oxford
uh i was a school teacher uh in fact i
was teaching during the first lockdown
uh so oh i applied to come here and yeah
so how come
yeah how come you switched what made you
decide to switch from teaching
into theology
or were you teaching theology no i
wasn't i was teaching computer science
but not many people okay so it's a good
question um
well i think
teaching was the start of my vocation so
before i got into teaching i worked in
technology um
online
mobile app development and website
development that kind of stuff
but it was all very superficial you know
i used to
make up quite a bit of money i used to
go and get drunk and have fun but it i
enjoyed myself but it was a very
superficial lifestyle
and i wanted i reached a point in my
life where i wanted something more
fulfilling and i wanted to feel like i
was giving back to society not just
taking from society
and
teaching was my entry into that because
we were hiring a lot of people
from eastern europe and east asia to do
the programming side of the design
projects that we
we worked on or we were commissioned for
um
and i thought that was wrong i thought
where's the homegrown talent was the
british talent and there wasn't any and
people come to us with really good cvs
like degrees in computer science but
they couldn't program they couldn't get
anything done and that showed me there
was something wrong with our education
system and i was a bit arrogant and or
naive enough to think that i could make
a difference so i decided to get into
teaching i jumped in the deep end one of
these where you learned to teach on the
job in in a state school and it was eye
opening it really was you know there's a
lot of work to be done in education so i
spent a few years in education i quickly
rose up to um
assistant principal um managed to make
quite a few changes in my school but i
thought this is just it's too small
scale i need to do something else
something bigger so i started consulting
for the department of education
and
trying that way and i did a lot of work
there
but all of this time i was doing this i
was feeling that this is just the start
of my calling this is like this is a
part of it the teaching is a part of it
and i figured that
we're sending young people out into the
world with really good academic grades
from some of some sectors at least but
no good character and i thought we
should be we should be producing good
christians and sending them out into the
world with good grades rather than just
entitled young people with good uh cvs
cbs
and i
discerned on that a lot
and realized that while teaching is part
of my vocation it is only a part of it
and the priestly ministry is what i feel
called to so i spoke to my my priest
about him there was a lot there was a
long process
in getting to where i am now but
uh
yeah god willing i i will be in priestly
ministry soon so it's been worthwhile
okay well i'm glad i asked that question
i didn't know that background um what
did you grow up a christian or is that
something okay so what's the story there
what happened um
well i always felt a connection
with god i always prayed i always felt
like my prayers were heard at the very
least but i've always struggled with
organized religion i think many people
do because you know
we see so much corruption
and scandals in the church
and it's problematic for people that
want to get involved and want a more
prayerful life
i think we just always have to remind
ourselves that we're all sinners
and everyone is fallen and any
organization that involves people will
have flaws and we can't get past that
there is you know we have to accept it
um so we've got to take the good with
the bad unfortunately with every
everything in life has to be you know
some element of balance but it took me a
long time to get to that point and i
think what it was
is that so my family are
nominally christian you know i remember
asking my mother
as a young child uh what religion are we
it's just like we're church of england
and i i didn't know what that meant
and my father was a baptist which means
you know they don't believe in baptizing
children they waited to all their adults
so they can decide for themselves
but i
later in life experienced
the mass
you know ritualistic catholic um
eucharist and if i felt something and it
meant something to me and it was
important and i didn't know why so even
before i knew the theology of the thing
i knew that this was a connection with
with jesus christ i know like i said
i've always felt a connection with god
but not necessarily with jesus and i
always struggled with that side of
things and something about the mass just
clicked with me and i explored it more
and discerned on it more prayed on it
more and i found out that this is you
know this is
um this is something i need to be
involved in
and i'm i'm
for i'm not a
roman catholic but i am a catholic i'm
an anglican catholic in the church of
england
quite a few of us
okay i've got a couple of questions here
then i guess let's start with why why is
it
so i recently found god in like august
so this is all new to me and i've just
been like grilling everybody who comes
on
so i've let's start with you said you
always felt like your prayers were heard
even when you were a kid do you why do
you think that is do you think that's
because of what your parents taught you
no i think we're all born with an
um
innate sense of
this this love from god i think we all
know it deep down we all know there is a
god and we all feel it uh some of us
work hard to deny it um some of us run
from it
but i think that connection is there
naturally
likewise we all have a connection to
natural law we all have a conscience is
is that part of that connection we know
the difference between good and bad it
doesn't mean we always act on it um and
it doesn't mean we don't get it wrong
sometimes but that is a god-given grace
like he's taught us his law and we have
to learn from it and work on it and try
and always head in that direction but
it's it's built in us
and i think that's something that
separates us from the animal kingdom
actually
not just a sense of reason but this
innate
uh knowledge of good
and and the sense of being part of
something bigger than ourselves but it's
quite humbling and i think that's part
of the reason so many people run away
from it because we live in a
narcissistic society where we have to be
our own gods in our own worlds everyone
wants to be the main character so to
speak and that isn't good
i think i had a hard time
i think because i was sick i was like i
was
like wishing i would say was i i wasn't
actively
praying because even though dad talks
about the psychological significance of
the bible we weren't religious in that
way
so i wasn't actively praying but i was
definitely like wishing
as much as i could that i wasn't sick so
and i was really sick how would you
define me to wish from a prayer
i don't know like it wasn't an act of me
thinking i was praying to
god it was you know i'd see any time
it seems funny now but anytime there was
some sort of coincidence so if it was 11
11 like 11 11 make a wish or you see a
shooting star make a wish and my wish
was always you know i don't want to be
sick anymore so i don't know what the
differentiation is other than i wasn't
consciously thinking god yeah
i was just thinking life right or just
reality reality if you would just change
a little bit
yeah
i think in the modern context we put
different words on it but i think
essentially it's always god that we're
talking to you know we're we're willing
something to happen we're putting a
message out there people say the
universal people say goodness or the
greater good or something but i think
what it is
we're asking god for something
yeah yeah i agree so
you grew up in a family that wasn't
catholic
but then you converted
so
is that what it's called i don't i don't
even know how to talk about this
properly yeah what would you call the
the that change
you could call it converted i i
i see faith as a journey and it's not a
linear journey it's not only a path at
all there are many ups and downs and you
know we will reach points on our lives
where we struggle and maybe move further
away from god and different points of
lives where we move closer to god um
but i think i [ __ ]
what i found was
a structure to my faith i found
something to help me articulate what i
believed and what i'd always felt in my
heart
and that was the catholicity that was
the ritual and the pomp and and you know
the liturgy the liturgy is so important
um
just
knowing how to pray when to pray and
what it means
uh just structure is you know it's like
any discipline i think we are a species
that require discipline and discipline
is liberating we're never freer than
when we are
conforming
as irony because that sounds
okay
so then i think what i've been become
more familiar with in the last number of
months would be
um i don't know if it would be baptist
exactly but some sort of protestantism
right that's just what i'm more and that
might have also been what i learned
growing up but that's just what i'm more
familiar with although my mom
is a practicing catholic
um but that's there's always been like i
haven't understood exactly what that
means and from the outside it kind of
looks like there's a lot of
rules and
discipline like you said but also
punishment that doesn't seem to be as
prevalent in protestantism and this is
just what i've been seeing so if you
could would you could you explain the
difference like why is it that
protestants also removed a couple of
books
they don't think that those exist maybe
can we start there and then
go back to what i was just asking about
um
so i think
a lot of it it comes down to
what is god's law and what is man's law
and i think the reformation and a lot of
the move into protestantism from
catholicity came from this idea that the
catholic church or the roman catholic
church had become too powerful and too
secular and it was
um impeding on people's lives in ways
that weren't to do with their faith
and i think the protestant movement
wanted to move things back towards
scripture
back towards the core books of the bible
and less
and take away the papal um infallibility
and all of that that's that's a
massive generalization but i think
that's the idea behind it
uh which has its pros and it's cons but
i think what i'm getting at with the
structure is that
we have thousands of years of people
praying and discerning on what the faith
is and
we are a faith of tradition we're not at
faith that we don't have a
holy book in the way that
the muslims have the quran that they say
is the direct word of god it can be
interpreted seven different ways but
cannot you know you can't go outside of
that scope it is fixed whereas ours is
tradition you know we have four gospels
uh matthew mark luke and john but they
are for among many they're just the four
that were most prevalent and survived
the longest um back in the in the days
of uh probably about 40 years after
christ had died
the faith was still being spread by word
of mouth and some people started to
write things down and some of those
things that were written down survived
but it's as much as it's inspired by the
holy spirit it isn't
the direct word of god not at least not
all of it anyway
so everything we take from the faith is
tradition so some of it is written
tradition and some of it is word of
mouth and some of it is ritualistic or
liturgical and the things that are word
of mouth and liturgical are maintained
through the catholic church and
which of course just means catholic
means universal so the universal church
which
at different times throughout history
has been more universal than it is right
now but it's just a way of maintaining
what we believe and things like the
creeds you know just like the creed is a
statement of of what we would call
um
our faith elements of our faith that we
we all agree are important to us but
there are lots of things
that we disagree on and it's
it becomes quite tribal but by the end
of the day we have to remember that it's
all about living life as christ had
um shown us really
yeah yeah no no no it did okay
that works
and then i i just have a couple of other
questions that have been hanging around
i think and then we'll probably move on
to something else but the idea so like i
said my mom's been
i'm just learning as much as i can and
trying to like feel things out which is
going splendidly but i'm also really
interested in it and like why are there
these differences and why have there
been so many arguments
you know if if the general principle
seems to be the same then why is there
so much drama involved almost um what
is it is my
like
understanding of catholicism that
there's more
punishment than in the
reformation i guess
um is that accurate
it depends um so some protestants are
far stricter than catholics you know
obviously the puritans were very rigid
and this is what we are and you must not
um drink you must not do this and that
whereas
catholics are more liberal compared to
puritans but then there are many
protestants that are more liberal than
catholic so it depends but i don't think
it's about punishment i think
we have to talk about sin and many
people shy away from sin because they
think oh you're saying everyone's going
to go to hell if they're bad it's not
about that it's about
the idea of our life is to
join a relationship so so god is love
and i know that's an abstract thing that
people say all the time but what that
means or at least what that means to me
is that god is an ever loving
relationship between the father the son
and the holy spirit they are three in
one one god three persons and their
relationship is one of love and god is
welcoming us into that relationship that
relationship of love and to get there we
have to head in the direction that
christ showed us so we have to live a
life of christ through christ and the
moment we step away from that i'll move
in the opposite direction that's what
sin is sin is separating ourselves from
god
so it's not to say that we are
bad people i mean we can make bad
decisions but it's not to say well bad
people by doing bad things it's just to
say we're not doing what we should be
doing i'm not doing good and not moving
in the right direction and the idea is
to teach about sin is just to say that
these are the things that separate us
from god so these are the things to be
avoided whereas these are the things
that make us better people who live
holier lives and should be encouraged
and if we shy away from the conversation
people don't know what it is to live a
life as a saint and it's so important
because
you know
again we shy away from the meaning of
hell as well and to me hell is i won't
say it's a literal place i would say
hell is the separation of ourselves from
god after we die um if we are if we sin
so much in our lives and don't care
about that connection and
disregard it then we put ourselves in a
in a place of hell
which is just
not in that loving relationship and
surely
um
most people would want to when they die
live in
the beatific vision and live in heaven
or or paradise or whatever you want to
call it living that constant
relationship of love with those that
we've lost previously but also our
creator
that's i think that sounds more
spiritual than what i've been learning
about protests
what i've been learning anyway
so yeah okay um from speaking with your
mother she's quite spiritual as well
right oh yeah she's been she's been way
out there forever
like since i was little like mom what
are you talking about like what planet
are you on
but now that i'm older i'm like wait a
minute wait a minute maybe she's the
same one she knows what she's doing but
it took me a long time
we've been pretty separated especially
when i was a teenager when she'd be i
don't know talking about something some
hippie stuff and i'd be like
what are you talking about
but more recently i'm like oh okay
i think i'm just not there yet mom
yeah some things in life you have to
draw the connections for yourself don't
you
yeah
this episode was brought to you by
nordvpn you guys have heard me talk
about why i love nordvpn you know that
episode with rolotomasi i did well i was
trying to do a bit of research on his
content when i was at a disney hotel in
december and they blocked most of his
content on youtube
fortunately or unfortunately i had
nordvpn their services are insanely fast
it doesn't slow streaming down like
other vpns i've used i can't recommend
it enough it's constantly helpful
especially on tour now they have a brand
new offender for my listeners grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com tmpp
or use the code tmpp
that's like the michaela peterson
podcast
that's the acronym i have to deal with
tmpp to get up to 70 off your nord vpn
plan plus one additional month for free
it's also risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee
and i that you said that you oh you
thought you always
knew god but you didn't understand i
don't remember exactly what you said you
didn't understand or you didn't know
jesus christ until mass yeah so what's
the difference what was your
experience difference between god and
jesus christ oh very good um
so god the father i always saw as
as
this
almost a deist you know a vision of just
some big almighty all-powerful being
that created the world is looking over
over us from heaven like quite almost
quite literal you know praying up to
heaven um as a child a very immature
vision of of what god is
and you know i was
through i've had lots of little silly
anecdotes as a kid um
i was bullied quite a bit um in in
middle school and
that connection with god is what helps
me just knowing that there's something
bigger than us something more important
than us our lives are trivial and small
and
there was something greater looking out
for me um and a lot of my prayers for
support uh whether it's for courage or
strength
or you know those kind of things
it was really reassuring um
and silly things as well you know we had
a
family cat that i really loved and that
cat disappeared and i just assumed that
the cat has gone away to die as cats do
and i prayed my little heart out for
their cat to come back
yeah and my cat came back that it did
come back after the prayer um so i
thought you know that's the power of my
prayer but i took the cat for granted
instantly i was oh the cat's back you
know gave it
first and got back to my normal life and
then the cat went away again the same
the next day and that was it i never saw
the cat again but i take that looking
back as you know my prayer was answered
i was given a chance to say goodbye and
i probably failed because we all fallen
we're all sinners and i instantly took
the thing for granted the thing that i
loved um as much as any other family
member um
but that's the same act my point was
that you know i always felt that there
was something greater out there that i
could talk to and that could offer me
love
and jesus
is is part of that but also he is more
structural he
he is the embodiment the incarnation of
god because he showed us how to live a
good life and what a good what good
means because good is objective um as
much as the word would like to tell us
otherwise uh
and that he is our connection to god to
the father like we
if we pray through him it's it's that's
a stronger connection um he's introduced
us to god and what god means and
that's why
uh the eucharist or the mass is so
important because that is the the moment
that we are closest because the priest
becomes impersonal christians that the
priest embodies christ and offers that
sacrifice on our behalf and we consume
the body and blood of christ therefore
making us one in union with him
and therefore closer to god the father
at the same time through the holy spirit
that's
um
if any priests are watching right now
they're probably gonna be judging my
theology but
that's that's the rough gist of it for
me
okay so then i guess my the part that
how do
okay how do i how do i word this
oh you said the priest
i can't remember exactly what you said
but you said the priest embodies christ
yeah
appreciation
so how does anybody know that that's
what's happening that that's what's
actually happening and that this isn't
not to be blunt but that this isn't an a
type of act
yeah oh yeah good uh
these are getting deep michaela um well
i think
the idea is that
this this is what helps because i talked
earlier about struggling with organized
religion and struggling with people and
not i did i've never never liked taking
leadership from other people i've never
liked
looking towards other people following
but this is what helps with that because
the
priest in the moment of the eucharist is
not representing themselves they are not
themselves they are
um they are a vessel
for christ and is this something you can
just like how do you know that is that
something you can see or feel or is it
something you're told like
i suppose it's different for different
people so
for example the
receiving of the bread so receiving a
christ's body
um
that's something that i've always felt
i've always felt that connection i've
always felt something
not supernatural but something
extraordinary was taking place even
before i understood what it meant
and then it does get explained through
catechism so as you're preparing for
baptism and confirmation these things
are talk to you it depends where you are
and how well they talk to you
that it is explained um what
transubstantiation means and and that
the you know it's it's that the the
bread and wine become
the embodiment of christ uh for that
connection and for for your spirit
for your
and
yeah it is taught through theology if
you have a if you have someone with
sound theology um but that's
the catechism is lost catheter's lost we
don't very often see um sound priests uh
passing on i'm not very often that's not
unfair of me we don't always see um
sound theology being passed on to the
laity and people just assume that
everyone knows what's going on of course
you don't you come in on sunday you sit
behind the pillar so you don't
feel
uncomfortable that you kind of go along
with what everyone else is doing and
sometimes it makes you feel better
sometimes it doesn't but we should be
teaching what's going on we should be
talking about it more
okay interesting
this conversation went in a different
direction than the questions i had
planned
i like it because i talk about workness
and critical race theory uh and race
relations and all those kind of things
and education all day every day but no
one ever asks about the the religious
stuff it's quite interesting
i've had it's been a while a couple
months
yeah it's been a while a couple it's
been a while like a lifetime but i'm
kind of into this right i'm pretty into
this right now i'm just interested to
see how
different aspects work and the like how
different people
you know come to god or communicate or
find them and i literally i'm starting
from scratch so it's pretty fun i know
it's your podcast but can i ask you a
question
yeah sure so how is it going how do you
feel that connection with god and what
do you do about it
so i had i've talked about this a couple
times now but i have had so many strange
things happen to me that i just couldn't
i've always thought about things pretty
logically and i've had so many strange
things happen that
the most logical answer at this point is
god exists because i had the i was never
an atheist i was but i was agnostic for
a very long time being like i don't know
what's going on um
but
just through experience i've decided the
most logical explanation is god exists
so i i only got to that in august after
a whole bunch of things that were way
too coincidental happened and it just
things just didn't make sense and i
think i saw
like a number of miracles within my
family and i was like well that's it so
then i've just been trying to understand
how do you get that connection and
strengthen it and
live your life in a way that strengthens
that
um and then you talk to some people and
it's like well read the bible
that's the main way
and then i've talked to other people and
they say well you need to go to church
or you need to pray a certain way
right and so it depends and it really
just depends on who you're talking to
and most people fully believe it
whatever they're saying so it's hard to
figure out
exactly
what's
right so i've just been feeling it out
right so i've noticed like if i if i do
read the bible and i'm able to actually
not just read it but like think about it
while i'm reading it like actually feel
it out um that can that gives me
this simply is saying it gives me a
sense of calm so if i'm starting my day
like that i'm just
calmer starting my day that way
right but a real real deep sense of calm
and
and i've been praying
to try and keep myself
thankful for the good things that are
happening not just pray when i'm in need
of something and so that's basically
what i've been doing now and i've been
going to i've gone to a couple of
churches just to listen to sermons to
see if anything kind of felt right and
nothing's felt
right
except for one time when i was listening
to this gospel this is not catholic i
don't think i was listening to a gospel
band and
that made me cry something that they
were singing made me cry and then they
talked a little bit about their
experience and then that brought up
emotion so i've just kind of been going
at this by talking to people reading
because i i still haven't read the whole
i haven't read all of
uh the old testament yet
um praying and then just kind of feeling
it out
to see what makes me feel like i'm
aligned and heading in the right
direction
okay so a few things from that um it's
interesting that you said you felt lots
of coincidences because it's often said
that coincidence is god's way of
remaining anonymous in our lives which i
quite like
when he said
different ways without it being evident
but
in regards to the different people
giving you different advice i think
actually they could all be right
yeah it feels like that that it it
really does i haven't talked to someone
where
it completely felt off i don't think
i've been like well you you're saying
this but you're saying this but couldn't
they both kind of be right and they're
connected right so the one's telling you
to read the bible if you read the bible
the bible will tell you you know one two
or three are gathered in my name i will
be the present and that's christ saying
you know go to church
so the people saying read the bible and
the people saying we go to church or you
know essentially saying the same thing
and i don't know if it would be helpful
to you but i wish someone had told me at
the time so i'll tell you about it
there's a thing that called
the the office
so if you want some structure where you
said you pray every day you read the
bible every day um this is essentially
parts of the bible but in a way that
every morning
and every evening you read something
different that's supposed to strengthen
you and give you you know good start for
the day and a good end to the day um so
it is it is scripture but it's in an
organized way um
because that's something that i found
difficult at the start like how do i
pray what do i pray
you know we all have different ideas of
what that means but for some of us a bit
of of structure helps
that's called the office and is that is
that a catholic
book is that common yeah i'm starting
from the bottom here yep so the divine
office is the catholic book
but also the book of common prayer is
the anglican um book and that i advice
both of them they're both fantastic at
what they do what's the difference
between anglicans and catholics
um
so anglicans are well
somebody in trouble here
a lot of anglicans would consider
themselves protestants
so the church of england is is
anglican in that it's not part of the
roman catholic church but there are
catholics within the anglican church so
i'm i'm part of it's not a sex but part
of a traditionalist movement within the
anglican church who stick to
catholic tradition uh whilst not being
under the authority of the roman
catholic church
basically okay
oh
interesting but this is it isn't it
anytime there's a group um of anything
of people that agree on something that
will always be schism because they'll
always be the finer detail that they
don't agree on and split on
yeah
so is the idea behind more of the
traditional
practices
that
actually physically practicing that
tradition brings you closer to god yeah
and why would that be
because i think i think that god came to
earth in in christ incarnate to instruct
us on how to worship you know he
instituted the eucharist by saying do
this in memory of me um to eat my body
etc he gave us instructions on how to
worship he taught us the lord's prayer
he told us how to pray so tradition is
important because the church fathers
have maintained that we've got something
called apostolic succession which means
that the the
apostles have passed on the
bishop
bishop rick so to speak down the lines
over the years
but that's important because
we have to shape our lives around our
faith but in the modern context i think
far too many people actually want to
shape their faith around their lives and
this is part of
identity politics a part of wokeness in
that people want something that's
convenient and they want to they want it
to fit their model so for example
there's a whole movement right now of
black theology this idea that you know
we bring critical race theory into the
church and look at it through a
perspective racial lens and to me that's
wrong because theology is literally theo
logis that's god study it's the study of
god it's not putting our color before it
or putting any of our identity before it
is putting ourselves before god
and a lot of the
progressive movements in the different
churches are trying to make us more
relevant
to social norms whether that's you know
things like
baptize it re-baptizing someone after
they transition from one gender to the
other or implementing homosexual
marriage or lots of different things is
all about we must be more relevant we
must be more progressive we must be more
liberal we must catch up with societal
norms and it's like no this is
the this is absolute morality this is
god's natural law this is the way that
he said we should live our lives and we
can't keep updating it um in in line
with modern standards because modern
standards might feel more progressive
but as we know progress isn't a linear
line you know there are ups and downs
and it goes round and round and things
that we consider
appropriate and relevant now in 10 years
time will be out of date and or wrong so
the whole point of it is to be counter
cultural in my opinion and that's why
traditional tradition is so important
because
as people get sick of modern times and
you know trying to stay up to date with
the latest phrase whether it's oh we
can't call you black male you're a
person of color we can't call you a
person of color you're not colored can't
call you that you're on our bipod you
know whether it's the language or
whether it's other things in our culture
people get tired
of not being virtuous enough and not
taking the right boxes and they wanted
they want something else i think that's
what the faith is the faith is outside
of that it's in the world but not of the
world and it's offering a different
solution it's a light shining in a world
of darkness
how do you how would you
tell somebody who isn't
religious
or and doesn't understand god at all or
maybe understand is the wrong word but
doesn't have anywhere to start
like how would you
try to get them to understand
i guess
yeah that's something i've struggled
with actually michaela i've been
thinking about this i don't think i've
done much conversion
um
not that i preached to the choir but
whatever i'm talking about i'm always
trying to
give people permission so a lot of the
messages that i get from from my
followers are things like
thank you for being unashamedly
christian
or thank you for speaking on this issue
it's given me permission to speak on
this issue or thank you for saying this
because i couldn't say it
um so i'm i'm trying to help
this what i call the silent majority
whether it's on faith issues or not on
other issues um
and that's that's what i've always
focused on but i don't really know how
to reach
the unchurched or the unfaithful
can do you think people can
or
or not because you see those like i was
always turned off
from religion by like you know you see
that bumper sticker i saw a bumper
sticker in the uk and it was i can't
exactly remember what it was but it was
like
faith or being saved it was either being
saved or faith is as easy as abc
and then it was it's all about christ
and then the bible and then
i think christ or something and i was
like that bumper sticker is why people
don't like religious people being like
oh well just do this and then all your
problems will be solved right so
and i don't think i came to where i'm at
wherever i am
at the moment um
i don't think that was necessarily i
think that was just a whole bunch of
life experiences that happened i don't
know if somebody could have come up to
me and then started telling me about it
yeah well yeah i think you're right i
think we're all on a different faith
journey and
uh it's like with anything in life we
have to make our own mistakes and
failure is what makes us stronger as a
person so we have to step away from god
in order to get closer to god at times
we have to make that mistake but i think
a lot of these people are disingenuous
and you know saying you know turn to
christ and all your problems will be
solved it's not as simple as that
nothing ever is
and i also think that when someone too
appreciates it's off-putting even now
that i'm you know training to become a
priest i see these street creatures
shouting helen fury and and you know
you must repent otherwise your soul is
lost it's like that is not going to help
anybody is it right
there's there's somebody
this that just reminds me there's this
old man in toronto who's at the corner
of the main intersection in toronto and
he's probably he's been there since i
he's been there at least for the last 20
years so i think he's probably 70 and
every time somebody walks by him he
yells believe really loudly believe in
the lord and it's just you just see
people walking by and just like this
because it's just this old man that
eventually
anyway
yeah yeah
okay
so how how have you seen
uh and do you have any plans to do
anything about this how have you seen
kind of this woke culture infiltrate the
church
oh gosh this is the worst so this is
what i'm fighting against on a daily
basis um you're more likely in this
country to hear a sermon in a church
about
climate change the so-called climate
crisis or about black lives matter or
about brexit than you are about jesus
christ that to me is sad
if i'm being charitable
i'll say that these people are
well-intentioned
and
they're doing what they think is best if
i'm feeling less charitable and more
cynical i'll say they've actually lost
the faith
or they've found a new religion
uh i think people a lot of people at
this point are worshiping
the environment and of course we are
stewards of the world we should protect
it and look after it but we shouldn't
worship it
it's become an icon
um
it's become an idol sorry uh
so that's one way it's infesting the
church but also i'm fighting against
this critical race theory nonsense and
every element of my life i started out
the reason i'm a political commentator
is because i was writing about critical
race theory infesting education while i
was teaching but it's infested with
church too
there was a priest recently who i won't
mention
by name
tweeted something about
um
a very good uh there's a very good
englishman called sir captain tom moore
who during the first lockdown he went up
he's like in his 90s late 90s he went on
walks around the country raising money
for the nhs for the national health
service very good thing he raised over
33 million pounds it was fantastic and
we're all applauding him great guy but
this priest uh put out a tweet saying
celebrating him is celebrating the cult
of white supremacy i'm like
this that's hatred you're no longer
preaching love this is a faith of love
you are literally preaching hatred
because you don't like white people
that's essentially what this critical
race theory stuff is about you know
diversity just means removal of white
people essentially and so i looked into
what these priests were saying he's
saying things like you know the bread
that we receive in the eucharist is is
white that's racist um the bible
mentions whiteness as cleanliness and
purity that's racist um
jesus is not white why people painting
and it's white that's racist and people
people like this priest i use him as an
example
that people like him see racism
everywhere but in order to solve it they
become racist themselves and they
perpetuate it and they spread the hate
but what's happening is the church is
supporting this and saying oh that's
very good this brown person said that
they must be right whether they believe
it or not they didn't challenge it so
people go along with it but other people
think it's fantastic and say yes we we
must eradicate this whiteness and then
the church itself the church of england
put out well first of all the archbishop
of canterbury the chief primate of the
church of england put out that said it's
a statement to uh general synod saying
uh the church is institutionally racist
and i have massive problems when
everyone makes a broad claim like that
without any evidence to back it up
because of course there are elements of
racism everywhere in our society
there are racist people everywhere but
that doesn't make an institution racist
unless there are you know barriers and
hurdles put up
that would prevent ethnic minorities
getting into this into the institution
or holding them down or oppressing them
in some way i've not seen any evidence
of that
structurally
institutionally but he put out that
statement and then the church put out a
report
called lament to action
that backs that up and said the church
is institutionally racist we need to
look at our colonial past and everything
these days is about the british empire
how bad it was and they forget that the
british empire you know had some bad
definitely had some bad elements in it
but also ended or was instrumental in
ending slavery on a global scale the
british navy i mean we only recently
stopped paying uh for the the cost of
ending slavery on an international scale
um the
british empire spread christianity
around the world the english language
around the world built hospitals
railways schools charities all around
the world it did a lot of good or as
well as the bad that it did and that's
never addressed but in the church is
saying hey we have terrible ties to this
british past we must be ashamed of
ourselves
um and then they put out a report saying
that the country is institutionally
racist and i have massive problems with
that because i think this is one of the
best countries in the world to live
which is why i still live here i did
spend a bit of time in america but i
missed great britain
and i think you know a lot of people are
risking their lives to come and live
here they're crossing the borders
international borders illegally to come
and live here because it's so great
i think it's wrong for anyone to stand
up and say this country is racist
without proving it or backing it up with
any evidence because everyone just
modifies yeah of course it is because
that's the right thing to say and as a
result of that the church is
basically performing what they call
positive discrimination or positive
action which is just discrimination this
affirmative action idea that we must
elect more black people onto church
leadership bodies um you know you know
whether not election uh what's the word
when you uh
just put someone on without an election
um it'll come to me later but there's
this idea that
black and it's with black people it's
not ethnic marriages in general it's
always for some reason it's more
fashionable to to
patronize the black demographic but we
must put more black people on these
bodies um so if no matter where you are
in the country there must be
30 percent black people and this is a
country where in london for example yeah
there are quite a lot of ethnic minority
people myself included but in other
parts of the country like places where i
came from
you would struggle to find even three
percent and three percent of this
country is black about fifteen percent
is ethnically minority ethnic minority
scientists so you cannot get thirty
percent black people on everybody
these things are arbitrary and made up
and they're people thinking they're
doing good and what they're doing is
actually causing more harm they're
stoking racial tensions and causing
division where often they didn't
exist to begin with
how much of this is just coming straight
from america especially that 30 percent
like that
is like
just all of it all of that this is the
problem the biggest problem with great
britain is america for some reason
every cultural fad that happens over
there like three months later i don't
know why you know the whole black lives
matter movement was massive over here
for for a chap a poor chap that died in
a different country uh and we don't have
the same race divide that america has
over here you know my con my parents
parents moved over here so my father's
parents moved over here in the 1950s uh
there was quite a bit of racism but
there was no racial segregation um
you know we didn't have to have a fight
for emancipation uh we had we've got
equality under the law and we've had it
for decades very very different picture
to what's going on in america um
and police brutality issues all that
stuff is very very different over there
so i don't know why we import the drama
and say oh yeah black lives matter well
i mean of course black lives matter all
lives matter why do black lives matter
any more than any other life and why
don't asian lives matter i don't
understand it i don't get why we're
copying pasting drama from another
country
yeah well
i mean the same thing happens with
canada but at least we're right above
america so it makes a bit more sense but
it's the same thing and for me i i
thought it was it looked like about
three months at least from
the us to toronto where where i used to
be where it was like oh if something was
cool then it took three months and it
was cool and it like for everything for
protests or style or
movies i mean it's like maybe maybe it's
a bit faster now but i mean i guess it's
the same thing that happens with
hollywood
style is picked up and moved over as
well
yeah absolutely so culture is a big
thing so over here
so people can often compare me to for
example to candy zones obviously i don't
have the same profile as her but people
made that comparison and i always refute
it because
people like that in america she's doing
a great thing by the way but she would
address the black community whereas over
here i would say there isn't a black
community to address i don't believe in
a black community we have you know
africa afro-caribbean people like my
father's parents moved over here and
integrated into british society whereas
in america they have a whole community
of afro-americans or african-americans
because they've been there since what
the 1700s and they have a whole
different history and they have their
own culture this whole hip-hop culture
and all of that has grown out of it
like just like the jazz culture did but
we don't have that over here but what we
do have is young black youths in britain
copying american hip-hop culture from
the way that the weather jeans are
halfway down their backside to the way
the way their baseball caps is like we
don't even have baseball over here why
are you wearing a baseball cap well you
know everything is important
he must have been fun to hang out with
as a kid
why are you wearing a baseball cap just
a baseball here
dad pull your trousers that's funny uh
okay well
so what are your plans that then
it when did you say you're graduating is
it called graduating
yeah yeah so i'll graduate and i'll also
be ordained god willing in june if the
church wow
but the church is battling me every step
of the way
oh okay
yikes
oh that's got to be a bit concerning too
with a bit of a public
um image going on yeah yeah so i
whenever i see nonsense i call it out
you know when the archbishop said the
church is institutionally racist i
called that out when the bishop of
london said that um you know she was in
charge of the covered stuff said that
the churches needed to close even even
though the government didn't go that far
so the church had went further than the
regulations said and closed all the
churches i think nothing is unforgivable
because we are a religion of forgiveness
but that is the closest
you could ever get to being unforgivable
denying people access to god denying
people access to the sacraments denying
people likes us to god's home the church
that was wrong on so many levels i would
say that it's actually evil
so i challenge that publicly
so the bishops the archbishops
um
see me as a bit of a problem
but i i say that's on them because i you
know of course i'm not always right but
i am always trying to preach the truth
and at the moment
we have and this is this is the thing i
was talking too far about actually that
we have an issue with there's a cultural
war against the transcendentals and so
truth beauty and goodness and i think
what they're trying to do the work lot
is erase
all understanding of those things so in
truth we used to think there is a
universal truth that we're always
searching out you know obtaining the
pursuit of knowledge but that's no
longer the case because truth is all
about my truth it's not about virtues
and it's about making something
objective subjective and the reason they
do that is because that's how they win
the battle you can't fight
feelings with facts it's just impossible
and that's how they win and they say
well you've offended me
we can't just say so what
we can't provide evidence
it's like the crazy woman who you were
trying to debate i just i'm like i'm
done with that
um and the thing with beauty and
goodness so with beauty
um
you know
i think the beauty directs our gaze
toward god that's why churches are so
beautiful that's why all the renaissance
art is the most beautiful art in the
world because it's all about god it's
about something bigger than ourselves
but these days art is about
being provocative and offending causing
an emotive response and it's often ugly
to be honest and it's often
there's a lack of mastery there's lack
of skill anyone can do it you know tracy
i'm in style take a photograph of a
messy bed there you go that's art no
that's not all it's not beautiful it
doesn't direct our gateway god and
anyone could do it therefore it doesn't
pass the test but the same with
architecture you know we used to build
things that were magnificent
and now we build things everything is
steel and glass and it's again i think
it's evil because
when i use that term i don't mean like
haha the devil i just mean it's
directing our case away from god it's
sinful it's it's the opposite of good
um
it's an absence of good absence of
goodness and goodness is the third
transcendental that they're trying to
raise in that
we used to try to live good lives we
used to try to be good people and that
we did that through moral
authority of the church or the bible and
now
it's easy to look good than to do good
and that's what virtue signaling is
isn't it i'm a good person because i
have a black square in my instagram or i
have a rainbow flag in my twitter bio
and pronouns i'm obviously a good person
and then in the same breath they'll you
know they'll call me uh racial slurs
or you know attack people they disagree
with with the most hostile language
vindictive horrible language they can
think of but they still think they're a
good person because they've got all
those tick boxes in place so they've
ticked all the boxes of being good and
we've broken down what it means to be
good now so truth beauty and goodness
are under attack and when we've lost
then we've lost our way of life
hmm
truth beauty and goodness
yeah
okay i can see that i can see where
you're coming from
okay wow do i have other questions okay
maybe i have another
catholic question
so i i think
part of what i've learned the difference
between protestantism
catholicism
is the idea mother mary is more involved
in catholicism right yeah so where did
she come in because i i know from what
i've been learning
she's not really involved at all
ooh interesting
so
yeah so mary's impression because
oh for so many reasons but so mary is
the new eve
so if christ is the new adam mary is the
new eve the new first woman the new
lady that shows us how you can live a
life without sin
um
rather than obviously the fallen
approach of adam and eve she's also
literally the tabernacle as in she was
the vessel
that contained god like she is the
mother of god um she she
gave birth to christ
so that's that makes her essentially
well ultimately important um
so what the the reason we venerate her
so much and we don't worship mary we do
venerate her we we ask her to pray for
us
because she is the closest person
to god uh being his mother and the queen
the queen mother and
in
you know the times of christ and in
different different cultures the queen
mother is the most important um person
in the monarchy after after the king
obviously christ is the king
in other cultures the queen
as in the consorts the person marriage
the king is most important but in the
time of christ it would have been the
queen mother the person the king's
mother would have had more authority and
so she has that authority in heaven over
over the saints and
we look to her
for guidance and for prayer and her
support and whenever we're in trouble we
can of course we pray straight to god
the father through christ but also we
pray to her to ask for her to pray on
our behalf and intercede for us is the
word we use
okay you said you said some sort of what
did you say uh some sort of authority in
heaven
yeah
so
she's the boss lady
how how do you know that like does it
say that some somewhere
how do you know that
so there is a lot of this
in scripture but you really have to look
for it um there's some good books on it
the jewish roots of mary is is a good
good one um but people far more advanced
in theology would be able to break it
down for you better than i could but
it's just
i suppose we just have to look at what
christ said and he's and what she said
and she you know she's she was the one
who
started his ministry off at the the
wedding in kaner she was
listen to him do as he tells you uh and
he was because he was like i'm not ready
yet she was like get on with it do it
perform your miracles do your works
um so she has the authority in that way
but also she was the start of the church
so on the cross christ said to john you
know take my mother in she's your mother
now and that was that was the formation
of the church john and and mary together
um
so there are there's lots of it in the
bible but it's not it's not as explicit
as other things
and i think the issue that a lot of
protestants have with catholics and mary
is that i think they think that we
worship her as an equal to god or
something like that
it's not about that it is about being
reverential to the mother of god just as
you'd be reverential to mother or anyone
important to your life
okay and then last question
what is this idea of purgatory
this is controversial um
so we've talked about how trying to
strive towards holiness and
live a holy life live the life of a
saint while we're on her on earth but
we're all sinners we're all fallen
we're all subject to original sin so
it's very very difficult for us to do
that very few people manage to do that
while we are alive
but to get into heaven we've got to be
purified um
there are
scriptural elements about you know
building the tower and god wants our
stones to be smooth people before
putting us in that tower uh the tower
being you know a metaphor for building
us closer to to him in heaven but
we our souls need to be purified before
we reach
uh the beatific vision before we reach
that loving relationship with god
in unity with god um so to get there we
have timing purity in purgatory and
purgatory is just that purification
process getting rid of last elements of
sin
uh on our souls and it's it's difficult
for us because we cling to sin as much
as we cling to uh you know all the bad
things in life we it's
we love the things we shouldn't love you
know
[Music]
over indulging in chocolate and wine and
things like that and that we all have
you know
our vices um so that the instant we die
they don't get
raised we have to work
our soul has to continue working towards
goodness
and is that
where is that in the bible is that in
the bible or is that through some sort
of tradition that you learn that
so
again there are hints at that in the
bible but it's
a lot of it is tradition but again the
bible is just part of tradition it's not
it is it is an authority but it's not
the authority in the church we have
tradition
reason and scripture and they're all
important and we can't put more emphasis
on one than the other because
interrelate okay okay
this is fun
i'm i'm slowly learning
i told you i'm meeting so many people
and they all have different views i'm
like where's the
where's the disagreement here exactly
and i think i'm slowly coming to see
where it is that is so cool
okay well
thank you very much for coming on that
was fun
it was nice talking to you again yeah it
was great i honestly didn't think we're
going to spend like an hour talking
about faith so it's been a pleasure to
me and i'm looking forward to seeing
where you end up on this journey
actually
me too uh if people don't follow you and
they work and they want to follow you
where should they go online
that's another good one i don't like to
promote one social media platform
because i'm terrified that i'll be
blocked and erased for saying the wrong
thing at some point but i'll say just
google me calvin robinson i'm on all
networks twitter instagram facebook but
yeah
i'm there okay and watch gb news because
i'm always on gp news
yeah that's fun okay well thank you for
coming on and good luck this summer
thank you have a good christmas and god
bless
thank you very much
[Music]
you